la nièvre fait partie à chaque
recensement des départements qui perdent
le plus d'habitants alors quelles sont
leurs idées pour animer les redynamiser
leur territoire une vaste consultation
citoyenne a été lancé en début d'année
les propositions qui ressorte ont été
présentés hier soir accru la ville
devant 500 personnes
marie-charlotte duluc bon baguet
le coup de vent n'a pas arrêté les
nivernais depuis fin 2021 1500 habitants
et 500 agents du département ont
participé aux rencontres citoyennes 10
organisée partout sur le territoire pour
recueillir les attentes et les idées de
ceux qui vivent sans nièvre
c'est aussi plus d'activités pour les
jeunes aussi des logements pour les
étudiants puissent de proposition pour
les écoles parce que forcément n'a pas
toujours
dg colle à notre portée ça peut
permettre un petit peu de
de démontrer au maire ou à tous ces
politiciens tout ça qu on a besoin d'eux
pour pouvoir apprécier pour pouvoir
grandir non dans tous ces petits
villages qui ne veulent pas mourir
qu'elle criait beaucoup de choses à
faire des thématiques comme les
problématiques de santé l'accès au
transport ou l'éducation des jeunes sont
notamment ressorties sur les 444
propositions une trentaine ont été
retenus présenté hier par des
rapporteurs citoyen beaucoup d'idées qui
viennent de la base pour aider à
développer pour aider à continuer à
développer département
c'est de type d'exercice que ce qu'il
manque dans la société de la démocratie
actuelle le plus marquant du sien c'est
par rapport au fond
la mobilité
c'est par rapport à mes doigts pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et
aussi la 12e position
ce par rapport la pénurie que nous avons
deux médecins les propositions devraient
définir une partie des priorités du
département c'est en tout cas
l'engagement de son président
et oui dans cette liste de propositions
formulées par les nivernais combien
seront vraiment appliquée lesquelles
marie charlotte de l'udc vous avez
interrogé à ce sujet le président du
conseil départemental
monsieur bazin comment vous vous engagez
à mettre en pratique toutes ces
propositions qui ont émergé tout
simplement en continuant le même
exercice durant toute la durée du mandat
en mettant en place sorte de comité
d'évaluation citoyens qu'on réunira
chaque année et puis en continuant à
aller à la rencontre des territoires
soit sur des thématiques comme la
jeunesse qui est un sujet qui est
beaucoup remonté soit de manière plus
générale sur l'avenir qu'on veut donner
à ce département quelques exemples très
concrets qui sont déjà mises en oeuvre
et ou qui vont l'être bientôt on peut
parler surtout de la santé où nous avons
commencé à créer un centre départemental
de santé qui sera installée dans les
tout prochains mois en tout cas avant la
fin de l'année dans le département